hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et utam le styliste dû cliquer
sur démarrer pour que notre aventure
commence je t'attends rejoint vite sur
messenger
[Musique]
santelli bagdad l'aîné l'aîné est ce qu
est ce qu est ce qu'on peut faire
ensemble
c'est là c'est ma chanson ce que vous
pouvez me dire ce que vous pensez de ma
chance hier mérite moi ce que vous en
pensez
scénaristiquement pas regarder vous
aimez ou pas d'ailleurs il y chante et
là c'est parti
ok c'est parti c'est là c'est la clé ni
celui bon là à partir de 100 brasse chez
le bart et là c'est latif occitana il
faut que je quitte l'aventuré
mon vestiaire ceni what do you think
about it funky show rooms compte que
c'est prometteur
[Rires]
non
les lits oui verrons mieux où est malade
you can't stop wiseman merci lenny
kravitz
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]